THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MARK STEYN.
VERY WISE.
>> THANKS A LOT, TUCKER.
PROJECTION IS OF COURSE THE
DEFINING FACT OF THE MODERN LEFT
AND FOR EVERY ISSUE THEY ATTACK
THEIR OPPONENTS AS WHAT THEY
ARE.
THEY CALL THEM RACIST AND EVEN
DID NOT HAVE THE COUNTRY FOR
THEIR SKIN COLOR.
BECAUSE HE JUST LIKES HIS VIEWS,
KRIS KOBACH IS A BIGOT.
>> KRIS KOBACH HAS DEVOTED HIS
CAREER FROM STOPPING BLACK
PEOPLE AND POOR PEOPLE FROM
VOTING.
THAT'S BEEN YOUR GOAL FOR
DECADES.
>> THAT'S AN OUTRAGEOUS
ACCUSATION.
>> IS COMPLETELY TRUE.
>> ALSO IF YOU LIKE PHOTO I.D.,
YOU ARE TRYING TO STOP PEOPLE OF
COLOR FROM VOTING?
>> CHRIS, IS THERE AN
ARGUMENT -- AND WE'VE DONE THIS
TOPIC A COUPLE TIMES BUT I DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND IT.
SO IF YOU ARE TRYING TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT PEOPLE VOTE LEGALLY
AND ASK FOR I.D., THAT'S
BIGOTRY.
FLESH OUT THAT ARGUMENT IF YOU
WOULD.
>> THE ORG EVENT ITSELF IS A
RACIST ONE.
THE ARGUMENT IS, BECAUSE OF YOUR
SKIN COLOR YOU ARE LESS LIKELY
TO HAVE IN YOUR WALLET A PHOTO
I.D. OR YOU ARE LESS LIKELY TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO A GOVERNMENT
OFFICE AND GET A PHOTO I.D.
IT'S BEEN DISPROVEN EMPIRICALLY
STATE AFTER STATE BUT SHE -- AND
NOW THE ENTIRE LEFT KEEPS MAKING
THE ARGUMENT.
I WENT INTO THAT PROGRAM
THINKING WE WERE GOING TO
HAVE -- HE OUT OF THE BLUE SAYS,
YOU'VE DEVOTED YOUR CAREER TO
STOPPING PEOPLE OF COLOR FROM
VOTING.
IT'S CRAZY, AND IT JUST SHOWED
UP.
>> Tucker: IT BUT I WONDER WHY
A SENSE I.D. IS REQUIRED FOR
EVERYTHING.
YOU CAN'T CASH HER PAYCHECK,
STATE AND THE HOTEL OR RENT A
CAR.
SO WHY DOES NO ONE EVER CALLED
THOSE LAWS RACIST, I WONDER?
>> WELL, IT MAY BE BECAUSE THEY
AREN'T RACIST AND IT'S NOT
RACIST FOR YOUR BANK TO INSIST
ON AN I.D. WHEN YOU CASH A
CHECK.
BUT OF COURSE, PULL THIS OUT OF
NOWHERE AND DON'T REALIZE THE
INCONSISTENCY THAT YOU JUST
POINTED OUT AND THAT MY
12-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER COULD HAVE
POINTED TO THEM.
IT MUST BE RACIST, NEVER MIND
THAT IT IS AN INCOHERENT
STATEMENT.
THE PRESUMPTION IS THAT THE
PERSON ATTACKING YOUR NOSE WHAT
YOU THINK, SOMEONE HAS X-RAY
VISION AND CAN SEE YOUR HEART
AND YOUR FEELINGS, WHICH WOULD
BE INSANE.
BUT BEYOND THAT IT HAS KIND OF
SHORT-CIRCUITED A RATIONAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE INTEGRITY
OF OUR ELECTIONS, HASN'T IT.
>> IT ABSOLUTELY HAS.
IN THE POSITION THAT VOTER FRAUD
EXISTS -- THEY SHORT-CIRCUITED
THE IMMIGRATION DEBATE.
IF YOU WANT TO INFILTRATE OUR
LAWS, YOU MUST BE A RACIST.
IT JUST CUTS OFF THE DEBATE
COMPLETELY WHEN YOU ATTACK THE
PERSON MAKING THE ARGIE, LIKE
OTHER ARGUMENT >> Tucker: I
TRIED TO BUY SUGAR       SUDAFED
TRIED TO BUY SUGAR       SUDAFEA
TRIED TO BUY SUGAR       SUDAFET
TRIED TO BUY SUGAR       SUDAFEC
TRIED TO BUY SUGAR       SUDAFES